director with the council on american
islamic relations
the nation's largest muslim civil rights
and advocacy organization
obviously we're here today on a very
tragic day to
offer some kind of response to
just a senseless horrific act of
terrorism
that took at least 49 lives of innocent
worshipers
in new zealand and we have a number of
people in groups
who will respond to that we'll
quickly go through the people who are
responding of
some good comments and then after the
end of the news conference we'll
take some questions first of all we'll
have a cares national
executive director had a wad that's
n-i-h-a-d a-w-a-d
care national executive director
this is a very sad day for all of us
i just woke up on a call
informing me that 49 people have been
gunned down
oh right shoulder oh
believes in white supremacy and believes
in the fact that what he has been told
what he has heard
that immigrants are invaders
let me say this
we mourn the loss of these 49
innocent people who were standing in
sincere
worship of god in two mosques
and we offer sincere condolences to
their families
and their loved ones
and we condemn this horrific
attack as a terrorist attack
motivated and carried out by white
supremacists
and we urge mosques nationwide because
today is a friday
and friday is the weekly prayer for
muslims nationwide
in the united states we have over 3 000
mosques
so millions of people who are muslim
will be in mosques in the next couple of
hours
concerned and fearful about their lives
if someone might come and hurt them
they have very legitimate fears
and they are being told to be afraid by
white supremacists
and political leaders who believe in
white supremacy
and we tell our community do not be
afraid
and do not abandon your masks
not today not ever they want you to be
afraid
you should not be afraid you should be
protected
you have religious freedom protected by
the united states con
constitution and we have full confidence
in local and federal authorities to
provide
the necessary security and assurance for
our communities
to go in mosques to mosques and not to
be afraid
not to be concerned about their safety
and the safety of their families
or children while they are praying
and we ask our political leaders
to address the growing
menace of islamophobia and hate
that has been perpetrated
by political leaders by ideologues
by people who want to run for public
office by people who
won public office on the backs of
immigrants
blacks jews muslims
and all minorities we hold them
accountable
because their words matter their
policies matter
the perpetrator of this terrorist attack
has been inspired by
hate mongers in the united states
and in europe the perpetrator of this
horrific and terrorist attack today
referenced president trump in his
manifesto
in this manifesto
years ago when another terrorist
attacked people in norway
he quoted islamophobes
like spencer and pamela geller
today the terrorist has quoted
the most powerful person in the world
president trump
and i would like to address mr trump
mr trump your words matter
your policies matter they impact
the lives of innocent people at home and
globally
and you should condemn this not only as
a hit crime
but as a white supremacist terrorist
attack
and you need to assure all of us muslims
blacks
jews immigrants that we are protected
and you will not tolerate any physical
violence against us because we are
immigrants or we are minority
you need to condemn this clearly today
and you do not need to be on you know
you do not need to be
vague you have to be very clear on this
and we are looking forward to hearing
from you
because your policies matter during your
presidency
and during your election campaign
islamophobia took a sharp rise
and attacks on innocent muslims innocent
immigrants
and mosques have skyrocketed
we hold you responsible for this
growing anti-muslim sentiment in the
country
and in europe but also
we do not excuse those terrorist
attackers against minorities at home and
abroad
our message is and should be won
we are united in solidarity we will not
tolerate division we have to stand next
to each other
in the same way we stood with our jewish
brothers and sisters
after they were attacked while
worshipping
in the tree of life synagogue in the
same way also we stood by our
jew by our african-american brothers and
sisters
when they are worship when they were
worshipping in the south colorina
emmanuel african church this
is the message that we are united and we
are also united against the trojan
ideology that sees immigrants as
invaders we should not tolerate this
hate speech
because hate speech leads to violence
and politicians can set a tone of
tolerance and unity
and they can also set the tone of
division and violence
and now we are looking at the results of
hate speech
and propaganda against the muslim
minority
thank you
and if you read the manifesto it's clear
that this individual who wrote it wants
to sow division
the very purpose of this act of violence
was to sow division
and to create hatred and to to
promote uh the people separating and
fighting each other and
obviously as brother nahad said the
answer to that
is to come together in unity and
solidarity
otherwise this terrorist or the
terrorist group behind him
ends up winning next we'll hear from
dr abbas bazagar uh cares research
director give a brief
synopsis of how the data we've been
seeing
shows what's going on in this context in
this country
and around the world
good morning salah welcome everybody um
my name is abbas barzigar a b b
a s bar zagar b a r z e
g a r uh as you know uh care has been
monitoring
and reporting on hate crimes bias
incidents and discrimination incidents
for quite some time our office is
directly responsible for that and what
we can
confirm is that there is a consistent
rise as there has been a rise
in anti-semitism attacks of
anti-semitism and others
there's been a consistent rise in
anti-muslim bias incidents
and hate crimes and attacks against
muslims at mosques
and although this seems to go unreported
or unnoticed in
media our offices around the country get
reports
on a regular basis of harassment as
as as innocuous or sort of day-to-day
banals things like
people getting harassed in grocery
stores and streets or getting chased
down on highways
to as terrible as uh as murders
you know in indiana just a couple of
weeks ago that no national press
actually covered
and so it's it's absolutely necessary
that we don't wait
until we have horrific situations like
this
horrific incidents of kind of global
importance
to pay attention to this issue i'll be
quite honest
right now it seems to be the case that
we only look at fires
but we smell the burning smoke from
miles and miles away and we ignore it we
say oh there's some burning smoke
there might be something and we only pay
attention when the fire is brought
directly into our face
i'll say that the fire is there it's
brewing it's international and it has a
source it has a cause
it has a structure to it and so the one
thing that we have to pay attention to
i'll depart from you know conversation
about statistics for just a second
is we have to pay attention to the
ideology that breeds this kind of
activity
hate has the same dna everywhere that
you see it
okay hate has the same dna everywhere
that you see it
has the same goals in mind the same
pathological ideologies that exist
in this manifesto which god forbid you
would actually take the time to read
exist in the manifestos of other mass
murderers around the world
they are directly related to ideas that
are carried out in
certain quarters in our own society that
exist in radio shows that exist in tv
shows
that have dog whistles by mainstream
politicians
by mainstream news commentators and so
we have to recognize that that
is the smoke that is the burning smoke
that's out there that tells us where the
fire is
and we as a community have to take
control and leadership back in our
public space
it is not the case that this is some
random marginal activity on the internet
in some kind of close dark web or
something no
this stuff is mainstream now hate has
the same dna
you can recognize it where it is and you
have to put a stop to it
we have to ask our tv networks to be
responsible we have to ask our social
media platforms to be responsible we
have to ask our charities and
philanthropic communities
to be responsible and not allow these
people to guide you know to
to exploit freedom of speech exploit
non-profit covers
these are hate groups special interest
groups with a very nefarious agenda
and we have to be able to take that uh
that activity back
so uh with that i'll leave if anybody
has any questions about the specifics
about the manifesto i can get into it
later i'd rather not go into those kind
of details here thank you
all right now we have some community
leaders
who are here to show their solidarity
with the muslim community in this
country and in new zealand
first of all we have david inouye
executive director of the japanese
american citizens league
good morning david inuy with the
japanese american citizens league it's
spelled i-n-o-u-e
um i'm the executive director of jacl we
are the oldest and largest
asian-american civil rights organization
in this country
is with the very heavy heart that i come
here today to stand with our friends in
the muslim community
what happened in new zealand is
unfortunately becoming all too common of
an occurrence
it's unthinkable that nearly 100 people
have either been killed or
injured in coordinated attacks on two
different mosques
sacred places of worship we can make no
mistake
the evil behind these attacks is too
often rooted in white supremacy
and exposed by the targeting of places
of worship
whether most recently a muslim mosque in
new zealand
a jewish synagogue in pittsburgh an
african-american church in charleston
or a sikh gurdwara in oak creek
wisconsin
for these killers nothing is held sacred
and these targets are selected
because of the religion that they
practice it's not new
hatred and discrimination have a long
history
the japanese-american experience is one
where
we were incarcerated because of who we
are but that didn't happen
just with the incarceration to build
upon what was said earlier
that began with the subtle racism
the discrimination against japanese
americans against asian americans
against chinese americans
and that's what led to incarceration we
don't have incarceration now instead
what we have is attempted genocide
we have people being killed because of
who they are and that is wrong
with all the talk of immigrants invading
our country threatening our way of life
the need to build a wall
it's actually the opposite we now have a
segment of our country that is eroding
the ideals of what it means to be
american from the inside
we are increasingly not a nation that
stands for religious freedom and
diversity
as in our first amendment and it now
appears we are exporting that hatred
and evil to other countries today is
friday
the day of community worship in the
muslim community and in fact that time
of prayer will be coming
quickly at the noon hour we hope that
muslims around the world today can find
strength in their community
as they worship together and know that
they are surrounded by
a wider community of other faiths and
beliefs that stands with them
together we will all continue to work
together to eradicate islamophobia
and other forms of hatred that weaken us
as a nation
and as a world community thank you
next we'll hear from yusuf ghazi with
the
d.c interfaith council
good morning it's usra ghazi
with the d.c interfaith commission and
also america indivisible
peace and blessings to you all we pray
for the victims
of the horrific attacks on the christ
church muslim community
for their families and for all those
affected by this most
vile expression of hate islamophobia
and bigotry in new zealand earlier today
this attack follows a line of similar
white supremacist attacks on places of
worship
churches synagogues mosques and temples
attacks like this are an attack on all
of us
and it demands a united response
many are asking what can i do to show
solidarity
for my muslim friends co-workers
neighbors and community members
i invite you all to reach out in
proactive ways
make calls show up at friday prayer
services in your area
and show solidarity both through your
words and actions
last night my mayor's office texted me
to ask what more can be done to fight
bigotry anti-muslim bigotry and hate in
our communities
i invite all elected officials and
particularly
those in local government to reflect
deeply
on this question we ask local government
officials to oppose hate speech
and hate violence in every form and to
be better
at tracking and reporting on hate crimes
we ask you to ensure that religious
centers receive appropriate security
protection
particularly during mass gatherings
we call on mayors and governors city
council members and county commissioners
to go beyond expressions of thoughts
and prayers and to respond to this
tragedy
by bringing people together in the
communities you serve
to affirm our human solidarity
all of us as americans can do more to
recognize the common humanity
of our neighbors and to build a
community
of inclusion that protects the rights
of all to live and worship in peace
and safety thank you
next we'll hear from engie mohsen a
policy programs manager with the muslim
public affairs council
good morning my name is anji mohsen
e-n-g-i-e-m-o-h-s-e-n
we at the muslim public affairs council
stand in support and offer our
condolences
to the christ church and new zealand
muslim community
at this time of mourning we encourage
people worldwide
to provide offer donations and other
forms of support for the families of the
victims
once information is made available this
type of violence
and the hate that motivates it is
unacceptable
in any form in any country
we have a responsibility to stand up and
reject it
no one should be made made to fear
practicing their faith
or going and attending their place of
worship
this strategy this tragedy occurred on a
friday afternoon
when mo when the mosque would have been
filled with people
who gathered for friday prayers just as
those in pis
in pittsburgh when they were attacked
and at their synagogue and the
charleston killer who attacked
an african-american church these types
of attacks are often
driven by racial ethnic and religious
hatred and every elected official has
the responsibility to
to denounce this these
attacks in the strongest possible terms
in the wake of this terrible attack we
call on elected officials to
to commit themselves to opposing hate
speech
and violence in every form but equally
call on citizens
to demonstrate acts of solidarity with
their muslim neighbors
and co-workers and others as an ummah
and as part of a global community
we stand in support of those impacted by
these horrific attacks
thank you
next we'll hear from medea benjamin
co-director of code pink
so i speak today as both a woman
uh a member of the jewish community and
a member of a community that tries to
stop
war and violence around the world and i
have one word to say today which is
enough enough i've been in these offices
before where we've done these press
conferences
it's not just issue calling on our
public officials to stop the
condemn what's happening it's calling on
them to change
policies as well when i see the policies
that don't allow people from muslim
communities to come to the united states
that is is it gives rise to
greater islamophobia when i see the
policies that keep people from
entering our country when they're
fleeing violence at our border
that is part of the policies that give
rise to hatred
when i see policies that are condemning
when i see people who are condemning the
two
new beautiful muslim congresswomen
that we have representing us that is
also very
painful and gives rise to acts
of hatred and violence and so
as we look around and we mourn and we
think of the families that are trying to
bring themselves together to figure out
how are they going to
rebuild themselves in the wake of this
hatred
we not only call on our officials to
condemn these acts
but to change the policies that generate
this kind of hatred
and as my fellow speakers here have
called out
we call on the community as well because
this is
a time for us to stand up for us to
reach out to people in the muslim
community and say
you will not fear worshipping
in this country because we will be there
to protect
you nobody must fear worshipping
in this country and so i just say
finally
let's make this the last time we have to
have a press conference here
to condemn such an atrocious act thank
you
next we'll hear from stephen miles
director
of win without war
good morning my name is stephen miles
and i am the director of win without war
a nationwide network of activists and
organizations working for
a more peaceful and progressive foreign
policy for the united states
there's no words to describe how
devastated we are today by the attacks
in christchurch new zealand
and on behalf of without war i'm here to
stand in solidarity with muslim
communities
across the world especially those
families and loved ones and communities
in christ church at this time of
mourning
today in the face of heartbreak and
hatred we choose courageous love and
unity
we recommit ourselves to dismantling
islamophobia
anti-muslim and anti-immigrant hatred in
all forms of dehumanization racism and
white supremacy
that fuel violence like what we saw
today at the al noor mosque in the
linwood islamic center in christchurch
no one as has been said many times
already today
no one should fear for their life in a
house of worship
no one should go to prayer to seek to
commune
with their brothers and sisters and be
afraid that they will face violence
that they will face intolerance that
they will face hatred and death
we know that this problem is not new
it's been said before we have seen the
smoke of this hatred rising
and when we see the fire we must ask
ourselves not just what
happened but why did we not do more to
stop this
why have we not taken action before this
moment to prevent this kind of
horror this kind of violence we call on
everyone
especially our elected officials and
political leaders to take a stand
not just with their thoughts and words
not just with their condolences but with
their actions
with their actions against the the
rising anti-muslim
and islamophobia that we see here in
this country
actions to confront this hatred that is
spreading
all over this country and now sadly all
over this world
we have had enough of thoughts and
prayers it is time for action
thank you
and finally we'll hear from catherine
osborne
executive director of shoulder to
shoulder
thank you that's catherine
c-a-t-h-e-r-i-n-e
orsborne o-r-s-b-o-r-n
i serve as the executive director of
shoulder to shoulder which is a
coalition-based campaign of 34 national
religious groups
us-based religious groups committed to
standing and working together
to address anti-muslim discrimination
and violence this group includes
the u.s council of catholic bishops the
union for reform judaism
the methodists the episcopals the
presbyterians and a number of other
groups many many christians and jews
from across the nation who are committed
to working together
to stand in solidarity against this
scourge of hate
we mourn together with the community
directly impacted by this today and all
who are feeling the ripple effects
of such an act of hate and violence
today we're tragically reminded that
hate is anything but benign
and we should be clear that the hate
expressed through the horrific violence
in new zealand
is not generic it's about anti-muslim
hate
which among other manifestations of
white supremacy
has become all too common in our times
we call on political and religious
leaders from across the globe to use
their platforms to speak
out against hate and to take action
against hate
and we call on people of faith and
conscience everywhere
community members all across to recommit
themselves to the everyday work to fight
hate
and to show up today with their muslim
neighbors to
to express their words and their actions
of solidarity with their muslim
neighbors
in the communities where they live to
let muslims in
the united states and around the globe
know that their neighbors stand with
them
the the silver lining i think in
situations like this is how many calls
i know our organization receives and i
imagine many others in this room also
receive
of support and solidarity we see so many
people who want to fight
against this type of hate and we have to
keep that going and we need support from
political leaders in particular in
in addressing this so together we can
advance a world where no one fears for
their safety because of how they pray
where they come from or what they look
like and that's the world we want to
bring forward thank you
thank you everyone if anyone has any
and that his questions matter be more
specific
it is no secret that mr trump has
campaigned
on white supremacist ideology
on division and fear he campaigned
against
immigrants against mexicans against
african americans against women against
muslims
muslims have received the lion's share
of his attacks he promised to shut down
immigration from muslim countries to the
united states
and he made that into policies through
his executive orders
he said that islam hates us
and he accused muslims of celebrating
the downfall of the twin towers in new
jersey
which was false and he was never ever
able to
substantiate that his repeated words
and statements and now have turned into
policies
have been impacting the mood the mindset
and also the lives of muslims here
and now we see that he was able to
normalize
islamophobia and to give legitimacy
to those who fear muslims and fear
immigrants
so it comes back to him and we tell him
that your words matter and your policies
matter
and if he would like to be the leader of
the free world
he has to change his policies and he has
to reset the tone
by recommitting himself to unity
equality not only in words but also in
policies
so he has a lot to do and we hope that
he will take the first step
by condemning this as a white
supremacist
attack and terrorist
the killer of this
tragedy in new zealand has cited
or referenced trump and mr trump should
reflect on this
very few people around the world admire
him
and now the ones who are admiring him
are the ones who see fear
of the other and he has a a role to play
in fixing this problem he's not the only
one who's responsible for this
but being the president of the united
states he has a lot of responsibility
to reflect on
any other
of questions this morning is sufficient
it's a first step but i think his words
are hollow
he has to condemn this as white
supremacist terrorist attack
and he has to commit that policies will
follow
change of policies otherwise we will
continue to see
the rise of anti-immigrant sentiment and
attacks
anti-muslim sentiment and attacks and we
will see unfortunately more violence
against
places of worship at home and abroad
as well um the author of the manifesto
to the question of whether he supports
donald trump he said as a symbol of
renewed white identity and common
purpose sure
but he also said as a policy maker and
leader dear god no
so it seems like he himself at least
didn't see himself as being led
by donald trump
you always have hatred and bigotry out
there
what donald trump has done he has given
legitimacy a fake legitimate
legitimacy to hatred and bigotry and it
has empowered bigotry and we see that
time and time again around the country
with the incidents we see on a daily
basis but
i mean many white supremacist attacks
are on the american muslim community
the attackers cite trump inside his
policy
so i i don't think anyone anyone any one
of us should be surprised
that what he says and what he does
impacts the attitudes and actions of
people not only at home but now abroad
and now this anti-immigrant sentiment is
is globalized
and the the leader of the free world has
a lot of responsibilities he should not
minimize
the importance of his words and his
actions and his policies
and of course no one's saying that every
follower of donald trump is a bigot
but there's going to be that tiny
minority
who take his bigoted words and bigoted
policies
and turn them into violent actions
any other questions um
yeah frankly condemning rhetoric is
rhetoric
it has to be backed up by action and one
of the easiest ways for congress to get
behind this
is to increase the capacity for
state local municipalities to report on
hate crimes and to mandate that kind of
reporting
the own fbi's hate crime statistics are
an absolute mess they admit it there's
no method
for us to even understand what's
happening out there okay so the
us congress can get behind by passing
measures
to force to force states and local
municipalities to report better and
consistently
on hate crimes and bias incidents do you
understand that there are states that
don't even have hate crimes legislation
on the books
and those that do are watered down to
the point that it's almost impossible to
hold people accountable for this sort of
thing
so congress should take a you know much
more serious leadership position
in encouraging states local
municipalities to do the right thing to
report on this
to make better sense of it and
demonstrate leadership condemning
rhetoric
is rhetoric
an example of the state without hate
crime laws indiana and we just had a
murder
in indiana by a man who witnesses say
three witnesses say was shouting
anti-muslim slurs
when he committed the allegedly
committed the act of murder so
any other questions
i tell them read this guy's manifesto
it reads like it was written in america
and it's it's clearly inspired by
the kind of hate rhetoric and growing
bigotry
that we're seeing in america referencing
donald trump referencing the quote
invasions
of immigrants all of these themes that
we hear on a daily basis
are referenced in this manifesto
this is the picture of a mosque that was
fire bombed
by someone who's motivated by hate and
this is one of many
we have been witnessing an unprecedented
number
of attacks on mosques we have not seen
violence against mosques
but we fear that it might be coming
unless and until our leaders take action
to prevent it so it could be in the
pipeline
and now head groups and and mongers
are networking among themselves
ideologically and i'm not afraid i'm not
you know surprised that they might even
operationally
be working together so we are here to
warn against what might be coming but
the impact of the policies that we have
seen
have caused a lot of suffering
psychologically
and also physically by preventing
muslims from coming to the united states
because of their faith
is a a messed up policy that has been
uh based on white supremacy and the
rejection
of people because of their faith or skin
color or national origin
yeah i just want to i just want to say
one more thing about this
it will be too easy to identify this
action as
a foreign event an isolated act of a mad
person
and it's also too easy to blame a
certain leader
trump or any other kind of person out
there what i'm telling you is that this
is trojan horse ideology trojan horse
ideology views immigrants as invaders we
know what racism looks like we know what
anti-semitism looks like
when you hear the word invading
immigrants
which we've heard in this poli in this
administration
and we've seen people send you know
stunt shows and circus shows of sending
the military down to the border to do
what
nothing except send the message that
immigrants are the enemy
all right this trojan horse mentality is
what fuels it so it's not about one
leader
who can get elected and put you know in
and out of office it's not about one
lone ranger out there doing something
crazy this is about an ideology that we
should all recognize by now
hate has the same dna whether it's isis
whether it's nazi germany
whether it's right now with a global
network of white supremacist ethno
nationalists of european background
trying to push back some kind of
globalizing tide
of integration and and harmony these are
fascists we have to recognize it
all right well thank you okay
well i think uh what we talked about
previously
is this the person or persons who
carried out this act
sought to create divisions so the answer
to that is to create unity to create
solidarity
reach out to your neighbors of other
faiths as other speakers said
reach out across ethnic and racial and
religious
boundaries and build those bonds of
solidarity and mutual understanding
and that's how you challenge these
people all right thank you all for
coming
everybody's available for one-on-one
interviews if you would like
thank you